[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Violaine de nuit
présidente de l'association biosom et
Lauren trouba metteur en scène
comédienne et Autriche bonjour bonjour
Alors Violaine Denis en 2013 vous fondez
l'association catharsis connu
aujourd'hui sous le nom de biosom quels
sont les objectifs de votre association
et quel est son histoire alors son
histoire elle dit à ma on va dire à mon
histoire personnelle justement donc j'ai
décidé de créer cette association parce
que je traversais une vie un moment
relativement difficile et du coup créer
cette association était pour moi une
façon de reconstruire ma vie sociale et
ma vie personnelle et surtout c'était
aussi une façon de redonner on va dire
le rôle de premier plan à des artistes
de Laura et là parce que pour moi les
artistes sont un rôle social et majeur
pour pour générer des rencontres qui
soient propices d'entraide de
convivialité et de réconciliation d'où
le nom de l'association L'Art de la
rencontre et de la la conciliation sur
votre site internet vous mettez en avant
le souhait de lutter notamment contre
l'isolement social le harcèlement la
maltraitance ou encore le manque de
civisme pourquoi cette thématique vous
tiennent à cœur c'est vrai que quand on
l'a lancé l'association en 2013 avec un
collectif d'artistes parler de lien
social c'était un peu conceptuel
aujourd'hui tout le monde va comprendre
de suite on sait maintenant que pour
lutter contre ces mots sociaux il faut
impérativement passer par la qualité des
relations entre nous aujourd'hui on est
tous conscients que on va dire 80% des
relations que nous vivons entre nous
sont gorgés de tension de malentendus de
violence donc c'est tout un travail de
travailler ses relations qui par la
suite vont générer forcément moins
d'isolement plus d'entraide plus de sens
de l'autre plus de valeur qui qui
justement va permettre de mettre fin
j'espère un jour tous ces tous ces mots
on l'espère un petit peu tous les
artistes sont souvent vous l'avez dit au
cœur de vos événements et de vos
activités si vous êtes invité
aujourd'hui c'est justement pour parler
donc d'un nouveau projet les ateliers
d'écriture spectaculaire un projet
tourné vers les maisons de retraite
quelles sont les objectifs de ce projet
et pourquoi les maisons de retraite
pourquoi les maisons de retraite ça
c'est une question bah je vais déjà à
laisser la parole à la parole à Lauren
parce que du coup c'est elle qui a dans
un premier temps m'a un peu sensibilisé
sur les EHPAD même si je connais le
monde des EHPAD à travers mon père parce
que lui-même a suivi sa mère et son père
pendant très longtemps comme ils étaient
en maison de retraite et à ce moment là
j'ai vu déjà que le personnel soignant
c'est des gens très dévoués et à
l'époque ils étaient déjà en
sous-effectif et tout de suite vous
observez que c'est des gens qui sont
épuisés éprouvés et qui n'ont pas
forcément le temps de s'occuper vraiment
des personnes et du coup mon père à
cette époque là qui donnait des visitait
plusieurs fois par semaine mais il
prenait le temps de donner à manger à ma
grand-mère qui était aveugle il avait et
il a couché donc voilà donc du coup
c'est aussi pour ça quand j'ai eu envie
de travailler dans les EHPAD
oui alors pour moi les EHPAD c'est très
important parce que c'est le lieu où
sont nos aînés et donc c'est des gens
qui ont une vie remplie de plein de
choses qu'on contribue à la société
pendant longtemps et qui se retrouvent
une fois âgé un peu rejeté un peu mis
aux bornes de la société entre
guillemets souvent les EHPAD ils sont
ils sont éloignés des villes ils sont un
peu cachés alors que les personnes âgées
ils ont ils ont une expérience ils ont
des choses à raconter très importantes
et ça me tenait à cœur de leur rendre un
peu de ce qu'ils ont donné à la société
et puis ce qu'on constate c'est que dans
les EHPAD les personnes âgées sont
souvent très isolées il faut bien
comprendre que la plupart des personnes
âgées n'ont pas forcément choisi d'être
en EHPAD et donc ils se retrouvent face
à un réel déracinement c'est à dire que
subitement on les prend chez eux et on
les emmène dans un endroit qui n'ont pas
choisi avec des gens qui ne connaissent
pas et donc ils doivent reconstruire
intégralement leurs repères et leur
manière de vivre dans ce nouvel endroit
et avec cette idée que ce sera
probablement le dernier endroit dans
lequel ils vont vivre donc ça peut être
un peu douloureux pour eux et pour moi
c'était important que par le biais des
techniques artistiques que je maîtrise
de pouvoir leur apporter un peu de joie
un peu de bien-être et que ça se passe
de la manière la plus douce possible
pour eux c'est cette partie de leur vie
parce que arrivé on est pas de c'est pas
la fin de la vie en fait c'est une étape
dans la vie alors vous avez évoqué un
justement cette isolement ce risque
d'isolement très très important quand
une personne âgée arrive en EHPAD il y a
aussi ce côté un petit peu silence
finalement une mise en place du silence
quand une personne âgée est placée en
EHPAD c'est aussi ça que vous voulez à
travers à travers l'art à travers le le
comment dire le théâtre c'est de pouvoir
s'exprimer justement à travers cet art
oui exactement en fait ce qu'on a envie
de faire avec ce projet c'est de
permettre de prendre conscience que
c'est pas parce qu'on est à l'époque que
la vie est terminée et que c'est pas
parce que on est diminué physiquement ou
sur le plan cognitif que on ne peut plus
rien faire parce qu'on reste des êtres
humains et on garde notre capacité à
s'émerveiller à rêver à espérer et on
peut encore écouter des histoires on
peut encore vivre plein d'histoires
plein de choses en fait et on n'a pas
forcément besoin de d'avoir ces deux
jambes et d'avoir encore plein de
vigueur on peut même dans un fauteuil
roulant faire plein de choses en fait et
c'est ça qu'on a envie de faire avec eux
donc à la fois de les écouter de les
faire parler de leur de leur permettre
de raconter leurs histoires parce qu'ils
ont souvent vécu des choses très riches
et puis voilà de pouvoir en faire
profiter un peu tout le monde et donc de
recréer du lien social en transmettant
leurs histoires alors comment justement
ce projet est-il né pourquoi avoir voulu
le mettre en place alors ce que Lorraine
a dit était effectivement important et
justement ce qu'il faut dire aussi pour
faire le lien avec votre question c'est
qu'il y a une étude qui a été faite en
fin janvier 20 après la période de covid
on constate que la moitié des résidents
d'EHPAD consomment des antidépresseurs
et un tiers est en situation de détresse
psychologique et cette étude qui a été
réalisée par le ministère de la Santé
bah c'est lié au fait que les personnes
vivent dans un dans une situation
d'isolement sociale très importante et
aujourd'hui on sait que l'isolement
social est un facteur de vulnérabilité
psychologique très forte et il y a des
moyens en fait de d'aller au delà c'est
de créer du lien social donc du coup par
rapport à ça pourquoi nous on veut
travailler dans la maison de retraite
c'est que maintenant on sait que quelque
part ces maisons de retraite elles sont
en situation difficile non pas parce
qu'elles veulent maltraiter les
résidents mais c'est parce que d'abord
le lien réel il y a le vieillissement de
la population maintenant dans les dans
les maisons de retraite les gens qui
rend sont de plus en plus âgés qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire des
pathologies plus lourdes donc ça veut
dire qu'il faut des aides-soignants qui
soient formés il y a un problème
d'effectif parce que comme dans les
médias on casse l'image des EHPAD
effectivement devient un métier peu
valorisé du coup ils ont du mal à
recruter donc à la fois vous avez des
personnes âgées qui ont des pathologies
lourdes et en même temps vous avez un
effectif réduit et du coup ben les
maisons de retraite elles font tout pour
au moins un minima offrir un suivi
médical faire en sorte de bien
accompagner des personnes âgées dans
leur quotidien ce qui fait que elles
n'ont pas le temps de s'occuper et de
proposer une animation qui répondent à
leur aspiration psychologique
intellectuelle culturelle même si les
animateurs actuels font déjà d'un très
bon boulot en proposant diverses
animations mais c'est vrai que ça crée
pas le lien ça fait pas de l'EHPAD un
lieu de vie sociale et là on a quelque
chose de à faire qui serait fabuleux
justement
vous êtes metteur en scène comédienne et
autrice de pièces de théâtre et de
compte quel sera votre enfin qu'elle est
pardon votre rôle dans ce projet quels
sont les étapes de ce projet alors ce
projet on l'a écrit avec Violaine de
Nicki est ici et aussi Laura days qui
est également comédienne et metteur en
scène et notre rôle là-dedans c'est que
alors je vous je vais vous parler un
petit peu de comment ça va se passer du
projet tel qu'on a créé en fait on va
arriver dans l'EHPAD et on va d'abord
faire une déambulation théâtrale qui
sera l'occasion là de poétiser le réel
des résidents donc qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire qu'ils vont voir des
personnages déambuler dans leur EHPAD et
leur parler et leur amener une petite
fenêtre sur la poésie et sur le rêve et
à l'intérieur de ça on va commencer déjà
à leur poser des questions aller faire
parler etc et puis ensuite à la fin de
ce petit spectacle on va leur proposer
des ateliers et dans ces ateliers on va
leur faire faire des exercices pour les
stimuler de manière physique et
cognitive donc c'est des exercices qui
sont des exercices de de théâtre
majoritairement mais mais pas que donc
voilà stimuler le corps la voix le et
aussi le rapport social c'est à dire
qu'en fait on leur fait faire des
petites choses ensemble pour essayer
d'installer la confiance entre eux et de
créer du lien petit à petit toujours
dans cette idée de justement de les
faire s'exprimer sur ce qu'ils ont vécu
de de d'avoir ce témoignage aussi de
leur part oui c'est ça
des on va leur parler en One to One et
recueillir leurs paroles et il y a des
moments où on va leur parler pendant les
ateliers à la fin des ateliers et vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure on veut s'axer
sur l'axe passé présent futur et donc
pendant les ateliers on leur fera parler
de leur présence et notamment de leur
futur et dans le futur ce qu'on va
essayer de faire c'est de leur faire
parler de quel est l'EHPAD de rêve pour
eux qu'est-ce qu'ils ont envie de voir
dans leur EHPAD et pour moi ce qui est
important là dedans ce qui me tient
vraiment à cœur c'est que je veux aussi
leur faire comprendre à travers ça que